se espera que este miércoles en una
nueva audiencia a la defensa de julian
assange pida oficialmente la libertad
bajo fianza para el fundador de
wikileaks para que mientras se resuelve
su situación legal de manera definitiva
aquí en el reino unido- pueda compartir
tiempo con su pareja y con sus dos hijos
pequeños nacidos mientras él estaba
asignado en la embajada de ecuador en
londres
entretanto eeuu tiene 14 días para
apelar esta decisión este fallo de la
justicia británica fuentes consultadas
por france 24 cercanas
assange han dicho que esperan que el
presidente electo de eeuu joe biden
pueda perdonar entonces assange
entretanto entre las organizaciones de
derechos humanos y de periodistas aunque
han celebrado este fallo ha habido un
sabor agridulce dado que assange no fue
extraditado no se concedió esta
extradición en primera instancia por su
salud mental porque hay altos riesgos de
que pueda suicidarse si es extraditado a
los estados unidos
para sentar un precedente a favor de la
libertad de expresión y la libertad de
prensa